haití primer país independiente de
américa latina y actualmente también el
más pobre de la región 11 2 millones de
habitantes viven en este país arrasado
en los últimos años por un terremoto en
2010 y el huracán matthew en 2016 tras
ambos desastres el país recibió gran
cantidad de ayuda internacional que ha
estado rodeada de interrogantes la deuda
externa del país superaba el 36 por
ciento en 2020 y la supuesta ayuda
internacional a haití más dependiente
del exterior la pobreza arrasa a la
población haitiana los sueños de la
revolución de esclavos que la llevó a la
independencia nunca se cumplieron se
calcula que más del 20 por ciento de la
población vive bajo el umbral de la
extrema pobreza en este contexto la
crisis derivada de la pandemia de kobe
19 sólo ha empeorado la situación hay
una crisis humanitaria con escasez de
alimentos y haití es de los pocos países
del mundo que no ha recibido ninguna
dosis de la vacuna a todo esto se le
suma la crisis política que estalló en
2015 hubo comicios en los que ganó job
en el mois el mandatario y asesinado
pero no fue reconocido por la autoridad
electoral
un año después allí comenzó la
controversia para moix en este momento
comenzaba su mandato para la oposición
un año antes
así moix defendía que su mandato
acabaría en 2022 cuando no se
presentaría a las elecciones el
parlamento está disuelto por decreto
desde enero de 2020 y la oposición ya no
reconocía la legitimidad de moix que
gobernaba ahora por decreto en febrero
de este año las calles estallaron en
protestas en esa fecha según la
oposición moix debería haber entregado
el poder desde entonces el gobierno de
maurice detuvo a 20 opositores por
supuesto golpismo que más tarde fueron
absueltos por un tribunal moi se había
declarado enemigo de la oligarquía que
controla los negocios claves como la
banca o la energía en un país que ha
sufrido el gran aumento del precio de
los combustibles ha grabado también por
la falta de envío de crudo desde
venezuela su otrora principal proveedor
las bandas siembran también al país de
violencia y se calcula que controlan
hasta el 60 por ciento del territorio
sólo durante este pasado junio ha muerto
más de 150 personas y otras 200 han sido
secuestradas en el área metropolitana de
puerto príncipe
capital que ha tenido más de 20
gobiernos en 35 años por el momento
nadie ha conseguido la estabilidad